This lesson covered how to use Tag
Manager to dynamically update your app.
You've learned
how to download the container
from Tag Manager into your app.
You used built in variables to
figure out the user's language.
You used value collection
variables with triggers
to determine which daily special to
show based on he user's language.
And you use data layer variables to
transport information back from the app
to the tag manager container.
In this case to push the user's food
preference into the data layer.
In the next lesson, you'll learn how
to use tag manager to forward and
manage hits from your
app to Google analytics.